hello everybody and welcome to another
Matt plot live in Python 3 video and our
little miniseries here this video what I
want to be talking about is styles and
matplotlib so matplotlib has this
functionality for styles and I was under
the impression that it was contained in
one of the newer downloads of matplotlib
however I could not find it the last
time I downloaded matplotlib but I was
able to find a third-party example and
so I used I've been using that and so I
thought when I did these videos hey I
get to use a new version of Matt plot
libs and some on a new version of Python
and I thought I could just download the
three you know version and find styles
but I could not find it there so someone
happens to know where they're hiding
styles in the original matplotlib
download let me know but anyway moving
on I'm gonna show you guys my version of
styles and so let's get started so we've
got matplotlib here we're plotting this
chart and just for example got this epic
chart you know it looks cool we've
charted stuff but it's pretty boring
chart so we can close out of that and
the next thing we want to do is we want
to add styles and if you're familiar
with like CSS like HTML and CSS you know
you have things called style sheets and
what these do is you can specify a bunch
of parameters to your style sheet and
then when you add new pages like new
content and stuff they just you don't
have to code in how you want it to look
it just automatically does it because
you've made this style sheet and that's
basically how matplotlib Styles work I'm
guessing they got their name from it and
so it's the same thing and then what you
can do even further though is you can
specify many style sheets so you can say
that this is the styles that I want to
use for line charts this is a style I
want to use for pie charts this is a
style for histograms and bar charts all
this stuff so anyway let's go ahead and
get started so come over here and we're
gonna have to first grab styles and so
I've uploaded my version of styles to
Python programming at net and then you
want to go
lows and then slash Styles dot zip or so
I thought oh sorry it's actually style
dot zip stop is it there we go and we
get our style dot zip download once you
have that you're gonna want to go back
go to your downloads here downloads and
where did I stick stuff there it is and
then we'll go ahead and extract all the
style here and then we get this and if
you click on style you come right into
here ok so just okay and then you come
style live and then here are styles but
no need to worry about that well we're
curious about his style right here the
style folder so then what you want to do
go to my computer computer or whatever C
Python 34 or whatever Python version you
happen to be using Lib site packages mat
what live and here's where you want to
stuff the style folder so let's move
this over here and then we take style
from here I just click and drag it into
here and now we have style mm-hmm
so let's minimize this minimize and
we'll come over here and now the only
thing that we need to do from this point
is first we have to import style
so from mat plot live import style and
just for the record importing style is
importing literally what we just moved
in so matplotlib style some you know
from MATLAB in port style if you
remember the tutorial on what imports
are and all that that's literally
importing this this file right here and
then it takes all of this and then
initiation or the initialize basically
is what we're about to do from core
import used context you'll see that
we're about to use that right now so
from a pot lid import style then here we
go style dot use and then we specify the
style that we want to use so if we come
back over to our distribution here of
style click on style lib we've got GG
block plot
grayscale and dark background all of
these I did not create these are pre
created by somebody else ggplot is one
that I've just kind of edited a little
bit I didn't really like the original
one so I kind of edit it and got what I
wanted but to use it all you you skip
MPL style and you just say we want to
use ggplot okay so now we can save and
run this and now we get a chart that's
kind of changed right so the background
isn't this ugly gray nastiness we've got
nice grid lines but they're not like
in-your-face black grid lines a red line
but you can see here that actually we
let's let's do let's just copy this
right here and paste and then let's
change up our Y a little bit six to six
and we'll call this x2 y2 and then we'll
plot some more stuff alt dot plot x2 y2
we'll save and run that and we see that
there's another color and these colors
are just more I don't know good looking
and the the natural colors that we get
so for example we can go back to what we
were using when you just comment on
style dot use I saving to run that and
here we are back to the original so it's
just got it just doesn't look that good
and so anyway we can start staleys
ggplot but then there's also these other
ones like dark underscore background so
we can go dark background and you can
see how easy it is to customize your
plots very quickly so this is a dark
background so changes all the data to
like lighter colors and the background
to black so we can achieve get out of
that and then finally we have grayscale
and this basically it just plots in you
know grayscale it's very true to its
name great right so we can save and run
that and we get this chart that's just
pure grayscale it actually looks pretty
good if you have a pretty complex chart
the grayscale charts can look pretty
decent right now it's pretty boring but
anyway so that's that with styles now I
do just want to show a couple of things
for example like if we let's say we
comment outside
that use an inch they'll probably
uploading this code so on and take out
great grayscale because it's ugly
oh look easy part anyway I'll comment
this out and I'm gonna show you guys how
you would actually color this stuff on
your own so here we've got X so let's
run it real quick just to see where we
are so we have this now so the default
plot close this close this and we don't
even printing length anymore so now plot
X Y X to it y2 now when you plot stuff
here's how you can change the color
yourself you can actually go we could
say the first line we want this line to
be blue actually I think the default is
blue so we'll call it green thank you
dog for barking anyway we'll call that
green then we're gonna say line width
equals 5 and this is going to change how
thick the line is so we can save and run
that and as you can see we've made the
first line this green color the second
one came out blue because we didn't
specify it so that's like the first
default color that's gonna come out
spoke what we've done here is we've got
green and as you can see a significantly
thicker than the other line and then we
can come down here and we can do
something special for this one too so
well instead of blue we'll call it C for
cyan and then we'll say line width
equals 10 this will be fun run it and
then here we get epic info we get you
know these lines here so that's just
some quick simple things as far as you
know changing some stuff now again there
are just an incredible amount of changes
that you can make and in fact let's pull
up ggplot real quick and see all of the
changes that ggplot makes for us whoops
that was it right here as we come over
here and immediately okay line width
changed for us face color which is the
background of background of things
basically face color edge colors changed
I don't even know what oh it's
anti-aliasing I don't know
anyway font size I actually change that
the default one has a really small font
the default like whoever made ggplot
face colors are changed all of your
plots are changed just for the record I
did this I added this list it's
basically the same list copy and pasted
over and over and over it says access
color cycle in Python 27 it does not
cycle through the colors once it gets at
the end of the list it just keeps
repeating itself the last color and that
was very irritating to me because I had
a plot that contained a lot of lines and
so that was very problematic so I
changed that I would probably assume in
Python 3 that's fixed but anyway that's
why there's so many there and then down
here it just is just commented out
saying what all these colors are x6 are
changed Y tics are changed grids are
changed line styles are changed face
color this is the face colored little
figures to the background there and then
the edge color is you know point 50 I
don't know what that is if that's a
alpha or what anyway so as you can see
there's a lot of customization here and
each of the ones like dark scales same
thing it's gonna have a lot of specific
customization to it normally these are
all things you'd have to type out to get
that to change but as you can see
there's a lot of things that you can
change about your graphs but again not
gonna get too deep into that normal
mining it too deep into fancy charting
or anything like that if you want to see
that you can check out the other series
I have on matplotlib so that's gonna
conclude this video a lot of stuff that
we kind of threw at you but really just
keep in mind styles and then you can
change line width congratulations so
anyways if anybody's has any questions
or comments on this video feel free to
leave them below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions
until next time